in the mcu do you think spider-man
and venom will ever cross over
just in your opinion not asking for any spoilers
tom's thinking so hard
For legal reasons, I cannot answer that question
We are venom
Welcome back everyone happy new year if you're
watching this video you made it to 2021 you
survived 2020 congratulations this is gonna be
my new spider-man 3 and venom crossover video
it wouldn't be the new year if tom holland weren't
trying to spoil some things about the big venom
spider-man crossover that sony and marvel have
planned i also have some thor 4 stuff as well
because not to be left out tom holland also
did a separate instagram live stream with chris
pratt where they spoiled some stuff from thor
4. it wasn't a huge spoiler but it was really
funny so if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's going to
be a lot of spider-man stuff happening really
soon because we're going to be filming outdoors
so hopefully we'll get a better look at some of
the spider-verse stuff that's been rumored so far
this is that clip of them talking about thor
for watch tom holland's reaction to what
chris pratt is saying it's actually pretty
funny i've got um guardians uh coming up
uh next year and i've got thor i'm gonna
go be in thor in australia so i'll be
traveling in australia in about a week wait
a minute did you say you're gonna be in thor
that's so crazy did it it went up i feel like no
one knew that bro no they knew that they knew that
i think they knew that no they knew that if they
didn't they know that oh well they know now
i love the way that chris pratt tries to save
face during that i'll talk about the spider-man
venom crossover stuff first that tom holland was
mentioning then i'll talk about the thor 4 stuff
because we also did find out about other guardians
of the galaxy characters that will be in thor 4.
but if you don't know what's going on earlier
last week tom holland did a special instagram
q a for the charity that he started and during
that fans we're asking him about crossing over
with the venom character obviously we all know
how that's going to go down because we know that
it's happening we just don't know when it's
going to happen or how it's going to happen
you notice though that the question that he's
asked is about venom coming into the mcu which is
much more specific and of course that hilarious
look on his face as he gets really quiet and
starts thinking you can see the gears turning
in his head and then he responds slowly with i
legally can't say anything means he knows exactly
what the plan is for crossing mcu spider-man over
with tom hardy's venom and how they're going
to address that in the mcu movies way back 84
years ago in 2019 when sony and marvel signed the
new sharing deal for the spider-man character in
the two new spider-man movies one of those was
spider-man 3 which they're filming right now
and then the mystery crossover mcu movie which is
probably going to wind up being doctor strange too
it was reported that part of the terms of that new
sharing deal also explained how all the crossovers
were going to work in the cameo scenes with venom
the other spider-man characters that sony controls
because sony ultimately wants to use tom hall and
spider-man in its venomverse spin-off movies not
just the venom movies like venom 2 but morbius
the other movies the black cat movie that they
announced they also announced a kraven the
hunter movie they're probably going to try
and do more sinister six spin-off franchises like
they're setting them up in the mcu and of course
they're all the spider-man into the spider-verse
movies just because they're animated you still
have to negotiate special terms for a contract
to have tom holland appear in those but before
they made that new deal marvel and kevin feige
reportedly didn't want to have anything to do
with the stuff the movies that they didn't
have complete creative control over because
before spider-verse became this big home run
and everybody loved it so much the more recent
sony movies had been pretty hit or miss even
though we actually found out that kevin feige
gave them some notes on some of their movies like
he gave them notes on the venom movie he didn't
really have any say in how all that stuff went so
obviously they just wanted to keep all that stuff
away from the mcu like do whatever you want to
do with the characters you have control over but
we don't want to deal with it but because sony
owns the rights to the live-action spider-man
technically it put marvel in a weird place
during this renegotiation for their contract
yet after the new deal was announced kevin feige
confirmed that mcu spider-man would be the first
quote-unquote mcu character to travel between what
he was calling cinematic universes just a sort of
multiverse joke because the multiverse is such
a huge deal during the upcoming marvel phase 4
movies like that'll all start with the Wandavision
episodes in a couple weeks so we'll talk more
about how the multiverse is going to play into
marvel phase 4 real soon if you go back and you
read some of those articles about the new sharing
deal the way they talk about the current plan for
dealing with mcu and sony spider-man spin-off
movie continuity is that the sony movies like
venom 2 and morbius any other big spin-off movies
are allowed to reference any of the mcu marvel
movies that feature spider-man that means they can
include any kind of easter eggs or scenes or call
backs that they want like spider-man homecoming
spider-man far from home captain america civil war
avengers infinity war and avengers end game as
you would expect though the limit on that is
that they can only use the spider-man stuff from
those movies that are specific to his character
like iron man can't suddenly appear in venom
2 but they can reference the snap the end of
spider-man far from home with his identity being
outed by mysterio obviously j jonah jameson is
a big sony character they're kind of riffing
on the version from the tobey maguire movies
then you have all the mysterio stuff he's a big
sinister six character they can reference anything
about mysterio that they want and he's kind
of tangentially related to iron man so they're
kind of referencing the avengers stuff through the
spider-man character and on the other side of that
marvel is allowed to reference anything they want
from the sony movies when tom holland's character
is involved so if they wanted to they can use
the venom character in the mcu movies or they
can just use easter eggs and references but the
whole reason for this weird system that they have
of referencing each other's movies in the mcu and
the sony spider-verse or the venomverse whatever
you want to call it is that if they want to they
can make it seem like it's all happening on the
same earth and it still makes sense that venom
isn't running around the avengers all the time
but there is so much spider-verse stuff that's
rumored in spider-man 3 with all these other
characters from the andrew garfield movies
and from the tobey maguire spider-man movies
that it also kind of seems like the multiverse
explainer is an even easier way to explain all
this crossover like they could just say that venom
takes place on a different earth and sony can do
whatever they want to with spider-man in those
movies and when he comes back into the mcu earth
and future spider-man movies they never have to
speak of venom if they don't want to talking about
all the thor 4 guardians of the galaxy crossover
stuff thank you very much tom holland and chris
pratt chris pratt trying to join the spoiler bros
in the mcu they've already started working on thor
4 down in australia all the thor characters have
been there for a while filming but recently you
may have seen all the news about the guardians
of the galaxy characters coming and going to
film their scenes and it seems like a much bigger
crossover than i was expecting i was really just
expecting a minor cameo with maybe like one or two
characters on board one of their ships while thor
is leaving to go back to planet earth but right
now with chris pratt confirming the peter quills
in the movie the guardians that we know are going
to be in there are peter quill groot because vin
diesel was spotted on set late last year and
he's the one that initially leaked the news
accidentally spoiled things that the guardians
would be in thor 4 and thor would be in guardians
3 but mantis was also spotted on set and i don't
know about rocket but i'm assuming that rocket
would probably be there too like they wouldn't put
groot in the movie and then not also put rocket
there because they tend to show up together but
the way things are going with all these characters
it seems like pretty much all the guardians
are in there mostly that's because thor left
with them at the end of avengers end game there
will be a small time jump obviously so that we
can see thor again being super swol he won't be
fat thor anymore for those that are wondering
chris hemsworth has been posting workout videos
for the entire past year just getting super ripped
and earlier this year taiko battiti also did a
big live stream with the cast of thor 4 revealing
a whole bunch of concept art and teasers during
that he also mentioned that the whole joke about
thor being fat was kind of overplayed at this
point and he wasn't planning on continuing that
like we did that already we're not going to do
that again in another movie i did a whole video
for all those big reveals and teasers so i'll
post a link to that in the description below
back at the disney investor meeting when they
were dropping all the trailers they finally
confirmed my theory the christian bale is playing
gorr the god butcher that is going to be some top
tier action right there and they've kind of
turned thor 4 into their next mini avengers
movie with all the crossovers like if avengers end
game was avengers 4 then thor 4 seems like it's
going to be avengers 4.5 in the way that captain
america civil war was kind of like avengers 2.5
tessa thompson confirmed that there were going
to be a bunch of big avengers characters crossing
over she didn't say exactly which ones just that
there would be a bunch of avengers showing up in
the movie so that's why it feels like it's going
to be a big avengers level event i'll do more
thor 4 videos when we get more news about that
obviously there'll be a ton more spider-man stuff
dropping really soon too but the next really big
thing that i'll be doing videos for are the marvel
Wandavision episodes that starts in less than two
weeks so make sure you have alerts enabled for
my channel so you don't miss any of those next
friday there will be some special episodes for
a series called marvel legends that's meant to
be like a Wandavision prequel so whatever that
winds up being i'll do episode videos for that
there's so much big marvel stuff coming in 2021
it's all going to be really really cool everyone
click here for that brand new Wandavision trailer
in doctor strange 2 easter eggs and click here to
watch mark hamill reacting to luke skywalker in
the mandalorian season 2. thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and happy new year!